Deadpool 2 is a cinematic blessing the likes
of which the world hasn't seen since Infinity
War came out two weeks earlier.
That said, the sarcastic, fourth-wall-breaking
X-Men spinoff is up there with the very best
of superhero sequels - like Spider-Man 2,
X2, or the second Godfather.
It raises the stakes, widens the world, and
racks up a bone-crunching body count.
The movie's got everything you need but a
free chimichanga.
Were you too busy laughing to catch exactly
what was going on at the end of Deadpool 2?
If so, don't worry.
We've got ourselves a cell-phone-quality camera
rip of this R-rated blockbuster, and we've
combed through it frame-by-frame to get you
all the facts you need.
So buckle up, family - it's time to break
down the insane ending of Deadpool 2.
Token of affection
After seeing Deadpool give up his life for
Russell, Cable is forced to reconsider his
values.
Thanks to Back to the Future-style time travel
causality waves, he can see that Deadpool
and Company's efforts to save Russell's soul
were ultimately effective, as his daughter
Hope's teddy bear is no longer being stained
with ash and blood.
Realizing Deadpool's sacrifice has saved his
daughter's life, he decides to pay the good
deed forward with a sacrifice of his own.
Cable uses the second of two time jumps his
machine is capable of to go back and make
sure that Deadpool's lead skee-ball token
ends up back in his pocket.
Afterwards, the previous fight scene plays
out precisely as before, allowing Deadpool
to take the shot without his healing factor
active and still survive unharmed, the bullet
deflected by the token instead of piercing
his heart.
"Tell me they got that in slow motion."
Time to change
The first chunk of the post-credits sequence
opens up a massive can of worms, giving Deadpool
nothing less than the power to rewrite reality
as we know it.
Along with her girlfriend Yukio, Negasonic
Teenage Warhead alters Cable's time travel
device so it can make unlimited trips, turning
the machine from a limited-use, last resort
option into a glowing "I win" button.
It's the worst possible power to endow a psycho
like Deadpool with, which N.T.W. seems to
only realize after she's handed the device
over to him.
Just like that, Deadpool is off on his very
own excellent adventure.
Unwasting Vanessa
Long before the wide release of Deadpool 2,
there was a swirl of negative buzz surrounding
one of the movie's test screenings, part of
which had to do with Vanessa being "wasted".
It's pretty cheeky wording in retrospect,
once you know she gets shot through the chest
in the movie's first act.
It's not played for a joke, either.
The overblown opening credits sequence of
the movie, scored to Celine Dion's "Ashes",
highlights how impactful Vanessa's demise
is.
It's all the more satisfying when Deadpool
uses the time machine to go back to the scene
of her death and bisect her assassin's brain
with a cream cheese spreader.
It's an insanely violent way to get to a happy
ending, but it's a happy ending we'll take.
Searching for Sugar Bear
The second task Deadpool embarks on after
saving the love of his life is travelling
through time to save the true love of the
audience - Rob Delaney's Peter.
After surviving the high-risk, high-altitude
parachute jump like a regular member of the
Army Rangers, Peter is ready to go all-out
on the heroism by saving the life of Zeitgeist,
he of the useless vomiting power.
The first time around, this selfless act resulted
in Peter violently dissolving thanks to a
spray of Zeitgeist's acid bile.
When Deadpool comes back to the moment via
the time machine, he sends Peter away from
Zeitgeist's crash site emphatically, letting
X-Force's most vulnerable member live to fight
another day.
X-Men Origins: Redux
With his second turn at the time machine,
Deadpool goes back to either the 2009 of our
world or the late seventies of the X-Men's
world to intercept the climax of X-Men Origins:
Wolverine.
That movie infamously ended with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine having a nonsensical duel with Ryan
Reynolds' proto-Deadpool, who you might remember
as the Merc with No Mouth.
The real Deadpool finally corrects the timeline
in Deadpool 2, capping his old self eight
or nine times while Jackman's Wolverine looks
on.
Widely-distributed masochism
There's something very Canadian about the
way Ryan Reynolds continually apologizes for
his past mistakes.
In the third portion of Deadpool 2's end credits
world tour, the actor Ryan Reynolds excitedly
reads the script for Warner Bros. Green Lantern
movie, sometime in 2010.
But this time, Reynolds' life comes to an
end before he gets the chance to make the
misbegotten movie, his blood and brain matter
being sprayed across the page as Deadpool
shoots him.
It's the bloodiest, goriest, strangest mea
culpa the world has ever seen in a superhero
movie, and the new Exhibit A in what makes
these movies so magical.
Aaaaaand cut
One thing that's bound to bug some fans is
the fact that Deadpool 2 apparently filmed,
and then cut, a scene in which Deadpool goes
back in time to smother Baby Hitler in his
crib.
Originally, the last stop on Wade Wilson's
Excellent Time Travel Tour was somewhere in
Austria in the year 1889.
There, Deadpool proceeded to do something
we all might not be brave enough to do, given
the chance.
It's arguably the most heroic thing anyone's
ever done in a superhero movie, but did it
go too far?
Well, someone thought so.
According to a Comicbook.com interview with
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick, two of the movie's
depraved screenwriters, the scene was cut
because the implications were just too uncomfortable
to end the movie on.
"I think it was cut just because it was at
the very, very end.
And it left the audience with this, 'oooh,
sure it was Baby Hitler, but it IS a baby!"
The next episode
While the final shots of the film's main story
seem to suggest more adventures on the horizon,
it's possible that those adventures won't
be solo missions anymore.
Like Weasel says in the Deadpool trailer,
they probably won't even make a Three.
"Yeah, why would they?
You stop at Two — you killed it."
The idea that the main Deadpool series may
be done isn't just conjecture, either - it's
actually something Ryan Reynolds has come
out and said.
Speaking to Entertainment Weekly, Reynolds
stated,
"I don't know that there would be a Deadpool
3.
I really don't."
Instead, Reynolds envisions Deadpool's future
as being one of a larger team, or half of
a partnership.
Granted, those are just where his thoughts
are as of the end of an exhausting movie production.
We imagine he's just being cautious.
In case watching him get his brains blown
out over the script of Green Lantern didn't
make it clear, he's clearly tired of doing
lousy superhero movies, and that's a good
thing for viewers.
Whether on a team or on his own, Deadpool's
future looks bright.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!